100 crepe
crepe cake 100 crepe layer crepe cake
100 crab cake
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys i'm scott i'm a tasty producer
and i've been challenged by brenda to
make a 100 layer crepe cake last season
we had a producer made a 100 layer
lasagna and when you hear that you would
guess there's a hundred lasagna noodles
but he counted like the sauce bechamel
when i'm going to make 100 layer crepe
cake there's going to be one hot grid
crepes let's get started we made a lot
of crepes on tasty this rainbow one is
amazing wow imagine doing 100 different
colors i'm not doing that what's that
feeling
i think it's just whipped cream we've
got a recipe let's get our ingredients
it's like i'm on top chef or something
flour sugar salt you got 10 seconds i
that's all there is
all right all right two tablespoons of
butter with the milk and eggs we'll
whisk that together
also
oh oh it looks like a sad omelette crepe
one pretty bad not oh
you got
it nice
[Music]
we've made four and it's been half an
hour
i want to get one of my favorite crepe
cakes in the city and sort of dissect it
make sure that my crepe tastes like
their crepe all right this is the best
crepe cake in new york and there was a
sign in there that said there were 20
paper thin layers of crepe they're not
counting the filling as a layer so it
seems like we're on the right track
counting 100 crepes it's mostly filling
yeah it's like a sweetened whipped cream
and just it's so delicate and thin of a
crepe i think this is good research yeah
i think i need to make my crepes thinner
okay i think
that's all i really liked
we're back day two i feel like i'm
pretty good going into today yesterday
we used three eggs today we're gonna use
24 eggs one of our tasty writers made a
post how to make a perfect crepe
according to a french person so now
we're going to take her recipe scale
that up to 100 and make a crepe cake
this is the biggest bowl we have in the
tasty kitchen i don't know how i'm gonna
get this in there
wow
so many eggs i could use a
about seven more people to help with
this
add the cooled butter
what
i feel good about this
[Music]
my hand is like i can't actually go
straight into my hands anymore this
looks right this looks like as creamy as
it's supposed to look we're gonna let to
set for an hour and i think we're in a
good place
[Music]
this is not perfect we're getting there
we're so close nice i need a paper and a
pen and we need to just start tallying
these up
yeah
it's still usable oh
what oh that is a good crate whoa hold
on
this is scary
oh my god scott this is i'm sorry 50
that was crips saddest celebration let
me know when we're at 100.
this is the 99th crate wow my heart is
racing number 100 coming at ya
[Applause]
all right it's day three we made a
hundred crepes we've had a bit of an
oversight here uh so it's not supposed
to be just whipped cream it needs to be
a pastry cream that way when like all
this weight is on top of it it just
doesn't squeeze out we have to make a
huge batch of pastry cream and then we
also want to make four flavors do you
have any advice on like how to tackle
making these four flavors
i'm thinking based on how i know to make
pastry cream mix in butter and vanilla
when it's hot at the end like get like a
stock pot and just like make pastry
cream yes just make one big paster cream
and then for strawberry i would get a
jam and then chocolate just literally
chop up some chocolate and throw it in
when it's hot and then it'll melt and
you can fold it in vanilla i just add
paste vanilla bean paste or even extract
and matcha when it's still hot i would
put it in like a fine sev or a strainer
and like do this and then fold it and do
this and fold it and it should be fine
i think it's all going to have so evanil
extract to just like the overall cream
and we'll kind of keep that just leave
that one plain then leave that one plain
[Music]
oh
my god what the heck is this something
vaughn said yesterday really stuck with
me he said i wasn't being original or
big enough i'm not in the business of
not going all out if we assemble this
crepe cake it's just going to be this
leaning tower of pizza situation this is
like cute it's a crepe
this
tell me we shouldn't be doing this you
know what i have to do
oh it's tearing this will go to the
crater
no
this is terrible
scott that's awesome that looks really
good
oh wow
i have lost track of what day exactly it
is we spent a lot of time with the giant
crate maker i'm not going to be
satisfied if we go with the smaller one
and yesterday brenda got me this guy it
makes them perfectly thin it uses less
batter we've got a hundred grapes to
make let's do it
[Music]
i'm
900 crepe right now
oh my god i lost count again nobody is
here
i think i'm losing it i don't think this
was designed to be on for this amount of
time so i'm overall impressed that it's
still working
sometimes life gives you crepes
[Music]
you got to make
good crepes and bad grapes that's not a
thing
this is number
almost 90. this is taking a lot longer
than i thought it would it's very late
nobody is here
here we
go here we go bringing in 90.
oh okay 90's not beautiful but that's
fine this is our this is our last crate
[Music]
[Applause]
i think it's done which means i'm done
for today at least at least when i made
the first hundred crepes there was like
a room that
fake applauded for me
nobody's here to celebrate with me we
did it we've got a giant grape creek 100
layer coming soon
[Music]
this is it going to work this is our
last day of the 100 layer giant crepe
cake i stayed after last night to make
all the fillings this is it this is the
last day make or break
this is going to be amazing
all right this is 49 one more and we're
halfway there i'm about to start crying
you're about to start crying his
adventure is almost done i still don't
know if the other pastry creams have
firmed up totally
[Music]
what layer is this honestly i don't know
this is 50 we are officially
halfway done
this is number 99
number 100
[Music]
thank you wow i'm light-headed we're
going to throw this guy in the freezer
dust it with some powdered sugar later
and then we'll cut it and we'll serve it
and it's going to be grand
[Music]
okay it's cutting pretty well
oh i feel every layer it's so satisfying
[Music]
oh my god
what
in the actual world
that's insane
can we get that in the freezer yeah
seriously
oh
god you're just gonna have to cut
another one you're just gonna okay i'm
leaving
uh and i'm gonna leave this production
right now so it's because it'll be by
himself
oh no scott i'm so sorry
let's just try to get something yep
we still gotta eat it
[Music]
steven's here to inspect if i actually
got 100 layers which i did so i don't
know why he's here
one
two
three
four
[Music]
9
100
scott just gave birth he's a new mom
giant crepe cake coming through it's so
heavy we've got four flavors chocolate
strawberry matcha and vanilla does
anyone want some
we did it we conquered the hundred layer
crepe cake and it was cool to see how
when i sent the message to the office
people did come down it is the biggest
craziest thing i've ever made i think we
made some people happy and that's what
really matters
this piece is much too large
[Music]
you